the suspect in the stabbing deaths of
four University of Idaho students
worried his family with bizarre eating
habits I've been following this since
day one somebody random comes in stabs
them all to death the other roommates
they wake up the next day at like noon
and realize what's happened however they
can't find anything for weeks and then
finally it's this guy he went to grad
school for criminology he like wanted to
know what it was like to kill someone so
I don't know what the [ __ ] this whole
weird eating habit thing is he basically
was vegan his aunt and uncle had to buy
new pots and pans because he wouldn't
eat anything that had ever had uh meat
cooked in him okay I'm the ant tell me
that my nephew just murdered four people
and got caught after a week long man are
you the aunt of uh Richard Coburg I'm
Richie Zan he's being investigated uh in
the murders of of four University of
Idaho students ah he always ate the
weirdest stuff I'd like to just know
more just what he was like as a nephew
what was he like he hate weird
is there any
[Laughter]